monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente Mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs les
députés merci mil000 fois pour votre mot
très
émouvant je suis flatté d'avoir été
invité par les présidents de vos deux
chambres à parler ici dans cette
illustre enceinte qui a été d'une
manière ou d'une autre la chambre haute
du parlement français depuis
1799 je suis bien conscient que ma
visite précède la rentrée
officielle des deux chambres de votre
Parlement et je ne peux que vous
présenter mes excuses d'avoir interromp
pour votre
PAE c'est la raison pour laquelle je
suis très touché par votre présence à
tous
Aujourd'hui la longevité de votre
démocratie est reflété aussi dans la
longue amitié que lie nos nations et nos
peuples notre partenariat construit sur
une expérience partagée demeure
absolument vitale alors qu'ensemble nous
confrontant les défis de ce
monde tout simplement le Royaume Uni
sera toujours un des alliés les plus
proches et un des meilleurs amis de la
France hier mon épouse et moi-même avons
commencé cette visite à la tombe de
soldat
inconnus là nous avons commémoré tous
ceux qui sont tombés pour défendre les
libertés si chères à nos deux
pays au cur de cette grande nation nous
avons rendu un hommage silencieux et
solidaire debout côte à côte avec vous
comme nos pays se sont tenus côte côte
si souvent dans l'histoire
cétait en ce même à l'Arc de Triomphe il
y a 16 mois qu'c cette générosité qui
vous caractérise vous aviez célébré le
jubilé de platine de ma trèschère mère
reisabeth à cette occasion le président
Emmanuel Macron avait décrit sa Majesté
comme étant le fil d'or nos nations que
ma mère est décédée l'année dernière ma
famille et moi avons été ému sont commis
une mesure par les hommages qui lui ont
été rendus dans toute la
France ce
matin j'ai relu les très touchants mots
de condoléance que vos excellences
président de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat ont écrit à cette occasion
vous avez décrit feu Sa Majesté la Reine
comme ayant incarné avec dignité la
permanence de la démocratie britannique
et qu'elle aimait la France la France
l'aimait je ne peux vous décrire ce que
ces mots ont signifi pour moi et pour ma
famille je peux seulement vous remercier
et remercier le peuple de France pour la
grande bonté que vous avez exprimé à
notre égard et à celui de notre peuple à
un moment de telle
tristesse dans la riche et complexe
tapiserie de la relation entre la France
et le
Royaume-Uni le fil d'or que représentait
ma mère priera pour
toujours je souhaite qu'elle nous
inspire à continuer de tisser des liens
entre nos deux pays avec
détermination avec espoir et avec
amour mesdames et
messieurs à la fois inspiré et encouragé
par les exemples de ma grand-mère et de
ma définte mère
la France a fait une partie intégrante
du tissu de ma propre vie pour autant
que je m'en souvienne d'aussi loin que
je m'en souvienne d'ailleurs j'ai été
frappé lorsque je me suis rendu compte
que c'était ma 35e visite officielle ici
en France et à chaque fois que je viens
je suis vraiment marqué frappé par la
chaleur de l' dont je bénéficie à chaque
fois et par toutes les bonnes choses n
pouvons faire ensemble lorsque la France
et le royi travaill
ensemble là à l'occasion de ma première
visite d'État en France je reste plus
que jamais convaincu du caractère
indispensable de la relation entre nos
deux
pays
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés au
plus grand défis de notre époque et nous
continuons à travailler pour poursuivre
les travaux de ceux qui nous ont
précédés lorsque le général de Gaul
s'est adressé au peuple français depuis
Londres en juin 1940 il a dit la chose
suivante rappelez-vous la chose suivante
la France n'est pas seule elle n'est pas
isolée elle peut faire bloc avec les
Britanniques
de avait raison de croire en notre
alliance de jours avant l'appel du 18
juin le gouvernement Deon churill
avait proposé à la France une union
politique
indissoluble qui aurait permis aux deux
peuples de continuer à se battre pour la
justice et la liberté en tant qu'un seul
pays et 2 mois seulement après cette
radiodiffusion historique mon grand-père
le roi George 7 portant fièrement
l'insigne rouge de la Légion d'honneur a
rejoint de Gaulle à morvolcamp à côté
d'aldchot afin de passer en revue 2500
soldats des Forces françaises libres
la détermination commune qui a été
exprimée ce jour-là a permis nous a
permis de
traverser ces années difficiles
douloureuses de la guerre et nous ont
mené ensemble vers la
victoire de notre engagement envers la
liberté et la démocratie reste
d'actualité aujourd'hui nos forces
armées Sîn ensemble au sein de la Force
Expéditionnaire conjointe
franco-britannique se déploie ensemble
avec les troupes de maintien de la paix
de l'ONU et par le Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU le G7 et leut assume ensemble
une responsabilité jointe pour la
sécurité européenne et
mondiale
aujourd'hui plus de 80 ans depuis que
nous nous sommes battu côte à côte pour
la libération de l'Europe nous faisons
face encore une fois à une agression
injustifiée sur notre
continent notre détermination et notre
alliances sont plus importantes
importantes que jamais
ensemble nous nous tenons au côte de
peuple ukrainien avec une solidarité
résol ensemble nous sommes
inébrbl dans notre
détermination que l'Ukraine triomphera
et que nos libertés si ch
l'orter ces événements terribles ont une
fois de plus montré combien tant de
choses qui nous sont chres sont
fragiles alors que nous faisons bloc
face l'agression militaire nous devons
ensemble
vrer afin de protéger le monde de ce
défi
existentiel le plus grand défi de tous à
savoir le réchauffement climatique le
changement climatique et la destruction
catastrophique de la
[Musique]
nature comre la nature pour
vivre dans ce sièle il commence à
comprendre que pour se vivre il doit la
la
protéger cette vision est encore plus
pertinente en ce 21e siècle malgré
l'empleur et la sévérité du défi auquel
notre planète est
confrontée il est encourageant de voir
les mesures prises par nos gouvernements
nos citoyens et de plus en plus par par
le secteur
privé je pense depuis longtemps que nos
entreprises peuvent jouer un rôle
essentiel en travaillant en partenariat
et en armonie avec nos gouvernements et
nos populations et investir des
milliards pour développer les solutions
qui permettront une transition réussie
vers un monde
durable avec le président Macron je
rencontrerai euh cet après-midi des
chefs d'entreprisees français et
britannique dans la collaboration
l'innovation et les investissements dans
une croissance propre et la préservation
de notre précieuse biodiversité font
partie d'un leadership mondial
essentiel j'ai réfléchi aux opportunités
que partage les membres du Commonwealth
et de l'Organisation internationale de
la
Francophonie j'espère vivement qu'il y
aura des possibilités de collaboration
future par exemple pour trouver une
façon de renforcer la coopération en
matière de développement
durable mesdames et
messieurs ns deux gouvernements
travaillent en parten
afin de relever tant de défis à
l'échelle mondiale et
néanmoins comme toujours ce sont nos
peuple qui sont le véritable moteur de
notre relation notre amitié et nos liens
chaleureux se renforc à chaque nouveau
contact entre
nous on le retrouve également dans cette
joie que l'on retrouve à chaque fois
dans la culture de l'autre et cela nous
rappelle à chaque fois combien nous
partageons de choses des millions
d'entre nous se rendent dans nos pays
respectifs chaque année et c'est une
joie que nous redécouvrons aujourd'hui
après la
pandémie des dizaines de milliers de
fans de rugby
britannique suivent actuellement leur
équipe nationale partout en France et
ils peuvent ainsi jouir du spectacle
fantastique qui est la Coupe du monde de
rugby d'ailleurs mon fils et ma belle
fille en font partie
et même lorsque nos équipes nationales
se font face sur le terrain
elles le font en faisant preuve
d'admiration mutuelle et en portant le
même respect aux règles du jeu et
d'ailleurs je dirais simplement pas de
Cuba et que le meilleur
[Applaudissements]
gagnant et bien
entendu il y a des centaines de milliers
de nos concitoyens qui ont décidé de
s'établir de façon permanente dans nos
pays respectifs cet échange tout à fait
vivant entre nos peuples nous rend à la
fois plus fort plus heureux et plus
prospère nos
artistes de s'inspirer les uns des
autres comme ils l'ont toujours fait M
l'ancien et le nouveau et créant des
uvres complexes et
enrichissante des inoubliables images de
Londres de Claude Mony et de bruit à
londonienne qui fascinit tant les
visiteurs français aux plus récentes
représentation sur iPad de David Hackney
des paysin changeant de Normandie en
passant par la collaboration novotrice
entre le designer britannique Paul Smith
et le musée Picasso à à Paris il existe
une universitalité dans notre notre
desion artistique
partagée en effet en ce moment même ma
chère épouse célèbre cette collaboration
artistique en lançant le premier prix
littéraire
franco-britannique qui récompense des
œuvres de fiction contemporaine
exceptionnel publié en français et en
anglais à
demain mon épouse et moi-même nous
rendrons à Bordeaux la première ville
jumelée avec une ville Royaume-Uni
Bristol c'était en
1947 ce lien commun n'est qu'un lien
parmi la grande quantité de connexion
qui existe entre nos villes nos villages
nos communautés nos entreprises et nos
établissements d'enseign
ce sont nos peuples qui grâce à toutes
ces actions mené communement qui
écrivent chaque nouveau chapitre de
notre histoire afin que nous puissions
léguer aux prochaines générations un
monde plus prosperère plus sûr et les
jeunes doivent donc être au cœur de nos
entreprises
communes je me réjouis donc de rejoindre
des jeunes du 19e arrondissement de et
de
Saint-Denis qui sont aidés dans le
incension professionnelle par le billet
d'initiative associative en soutenant
des jeunes nous investissons dans notre
avenir un un investissement qui sera
remboursé d'innomrables
fois monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente mesames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs les
députés il y a près de 120 ans mon
arrière arrière grand-père le roi
éedouard VI s'est engagé au nom de
royonie pour l'entente codiale et le
lien entre nos deux
pays ce lien fut sanctifié par les
sacrifices
incomensurables du siècle dernier et
poit par chaque exemple de notre projet
commun aujourd'hui il est d'entre nos
mains après avoir été transmis avec
fierté de père en fille de mère en fils
tout comme il a été à travers les
générations de ma propre
famille pendant le temps qui m'est
accordé en tant que
roi je m'engage
à faire tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir
et en mon pouvoir pour renforcer la
relation indispensable
entre le Royaume-Uni et la
France et
aujourd'hui je vous invite à vous
joindre à moi dans cet effort
ensemble notre potentiel est
illimité c'est pourquoi nous devons
chérir
et entretenir notre entente
cordiale renouvelons là pour les
générations futur afin qu'elle devienne
je le propose également une entente pour
la
durbilité pour répondre plus
efficacement à l'ence mondiale en
matière de climat et de
biodiversité l'engagement les uns envers
les autres et envers les valeurs que que
nous partageons si fierment un
engagement inspiré par l'exemple du
passé et en courourgé à relever les
immenses défis du monde qui nous
entourent en tant que voisin amis
partenaire et alliés il n'y a pas de
défi que nous ne puissions relever comme
nous l'avons fait si souvent par le
passé allons de l'avant avec espoir et
courage et faisons-le
ensemble
merci
[Musique]